now controversial influencer andrew tate
has been banned from facebook and
instagram for violating its policies
around dangerous individuals the
kickboxer has gained notoriety online
for his misogynistic and offensive
comments towards women the decision has
been hailed by a number of campaign
groups which claim mr tate poses a
genuine threat to young people
well joining me now is activist and
author of the upcoming book titled how
to stay safe online shayi shay akiwawo
thanks for joining us today so
for the uninitiated could you just
explain who andrew tate is and what
exactly it is that he's doing
well thank you so much for having me um
i'm to summarize andrew tate he is
somebody that has used his platform to
spread hate online particularly against
women and misogyny misogynistic content
but andrew t isn't the only person who
does this online and is able to make a
lot of profit from hate and so it will
be remiss of us to make this
conversation just about taped and not
about the systems and the culture in
which breeds people like tate and also
thinks makes it that this career is
attractive to people
and when it comes to
andrew tate how has he been so
successful in spreading these horrible
messages
i think what you're having at the moment
is textbook uh grooming which is why um
i think it's really important to be
seeing in cells who i would however
describe andrew tapes as an extremist
group somebody who is using minoritized
communities um as a way to blame and
excuse behavior um particularly of those
who are disgruntled and we're seeing
this
increase right now with the cost of
living a lot of people are are worried
are confused are looking for someone to
blame and you have people like andrew
tate who use um vulnerable and
disgruntled people and motivate them to
turn against minoritized communities
which is not what we should be doing in
in times like this we should be banding
together and platforms shouldn't be
allowing such content to exist on a
platform let alone amplifying them
so understand he's been banned from
facebook and instagram but lots of his
videos still live on on other platforms
like tick tock
how will it ever stop
well i've been calling for tik tok and
other platforms to be having a label on
any content relating to andrew tate just
as we saw during the covid um lockdowns
where we saw anything that had related
to covert content was labeled and then
directed to a more trustworthy source
and we should be seeing the same
resourcing and commitment to
misinformation and hate speech that we
saw in the lockdowns actually um to
misogyny and other forms of hate crime
it's it seems a bit weird that the same
resources that existed for for
misinformation around the around kovid
doesn't exist when it comes to a man
spreading absolute lies about about
women online
and you mentioned that andrew tate isn't
the only one spreading this sort of
thing online
how big is the problem across the
internet
i think the the problem is pretty big
and it's huge we saw this time last year
jake davidson killed five people in a
mass shooting in plymouth
and he was involved in a lot of online
misogynistic exchange just beforehand
we've seen a lot of shootings in america
uh which we can trace back to um online
misogynistic content not being taken
seriously online and so there is a real
danger of this not just staying online
and growing but actually impacting our
offline lives too and so i think it's
really important that we have all social
media companies not make this a pr stunt
about tape but make sure that they have
systems that take extremist content like
this seriously
and i'm sure it's not just children and
young people who are being affected by
this sort of
younger adults as well are involved what
advice would you have for any parents or
perhaps even friends who know of people
who are looking at this sort of content
online
yeah it's a it's a tough one but my my
biggest advice is just making sure
you're giving yourself that time to
critically engage with the content it's
so easy to be bombarded by content and
and information that we need to make
sure actually is fact and true and i
think parents can play a really great
role in being that trusted adult in
young people's life where they can come
to them and be like i've seen this thing
is it true and that means parents be
providing a very warming um and open
dialogue and culture and and and and
wanting to have a conversation about our
online behaviors and i think parents can
really role model their experiences too
and i think this ultimately comes down
to education we need to be seeing
platforms um invest more in educating
users about how to use their platform
safely and governments too it doesn't
make any sense that we are now using
text so much more every day and yet we
haven't been given the the tools in
which to navigate these spaces safely
because there is a lot of dangers out
there not just tape there is so much
more out there that we're not being
properly equipped to and i talk about
this in my book how to stay safe online
as a way of starting the conversation
around how we can better prepare
ourselves for navigating online spaces
like social media
and just quickly uh last thought then
what one thing would you suggest is the
best way to prepare ourselves to be safe
online
oh you're putting me on the spot there
chloe if i had to choose i would say
setting intentions around how you want
to use the online space and feeling that
you are able to stick up for your
beliefs online in a way that doesn't now
hurt or offend somebody else i think we
see a lot of bystanders online that see
this content and think oh that's
actually not appropriate but don't do
anything about it actually if more of us
were reporting and and calling out um
people like andrew tate and other
misinformation online and hate speech we
would actually have a much kinder um and
safer online experience
author of the how to stay safe online
new book and activist thanks so much for
joining us today
thank you